an update now to the breaking news we  shared at the very top of the hour we  are learning more about the ongoing  incident near owens and h street let's  get right back out to madison kimbrough  who joins us now live with that update  yes one person is dead and another taken  to the hospital now take a look as it's  a very active scene behind me we don't  know what type of injuries or condition  that person is in now owens avenue is  blocked off with crime scene tape road  is closed it looks like the incident  happened at or around bell's market  still a very active scene with multiple  police cars like we mentioned one person  is dead another taken to the hospital  their condition currently is unknown  reporting live madison kimbrough live  local now